hello
my name is li ninfu and i will be
talking about a dao
which i developed in my free time as
well
so in this talk i will first give you
give you some
overview about the language
and some features and then i will select
some
example phases to explain in a little
bit more details
then i will spend more time to talk
about the concurrent
programming because i think this is
one of the major faces of this language
then i will also speak about the
jitter compiler which is based on
llvm then i will also mention a tool i
developed based on clan
which you can gel with bindings
from c c plus plus library
head files automatically
then well i will also show a screenshot
of an ide which i developed for now
and then i will also mention some
future development plans
so for the motivation of this language
[Music]
initially it was motivated by prayer
i i had to write some pair scripts
but i had a lot of frustration
with this language so i got very curious
about the
language design and imagination so at
the moment one of my questions how hard
it is to develop a good language
then i also wanted to have a good
better programming language for
bioinformatics
which was the field i was working on
but eventually the goal had become to to
create a
general purpose programming language
which
offers advanced features with a small
run time
so this language emphasis on
emphasis on rich but long redundant
data types and features and and it also
should have
consistent and reasonably designed
centers
so it i also wanted this language to be
very easily extendable and embeddable
so it also offers a
simple programming interface
i also intended this language to be
usable in numerical communication
so the design and imagination
it's mostly optimized for
numerical computation and also
because now
multiple computers are quite popular so
i also
try to support them
some concurrent programming phases in
this language
so for new language i think most people
will have one of the first questions
how this language look like so this is
how this language look like
in the left um the code has low type
annotations so it has increased
implicit types in the right side
the code has well annotated types
so you can you can see it's most dc plus
like but with with
some exceptions
and also you may wonder what kind of
performance you can expect from this
language
so i will show some benchmarks in one of
the first
slides so here's some benchmark i did
with the programs from the
program language benchmark games
so you can see that here is
the computational time for this
those blue lines in tao with dao and
here it starts with the jitter companion
and heavily the speed up so here it is
the same program
equivalent programs in lower python and
c so you can see that the dow
is the loop is relationally fast and
intensely in tempurated language
but it's loaded very fast so it's
quite slow compared to c
and for the city compiling the speed up
is
good for some problems but for others
it it simply
don't work because now it can only
compile a subset of for
merchant strategies
so here i will just use some key phases
of this language
so first of all it's optional optional
typed with the type influence and
aesthetic typing
type checking and then it has the bmf
bmf like syntax micro for defining
customized syntax it has native support
for concurrent programming
and every vm-based static compiling
and it also has simple c interfaces for
for inverting and extending that many
other features
i will not read them out but i will see
some of
them to explain in the following slides
there are some also there are also some
modules and tools
i developed for this language
[Music]
i i will briefly mention clandal
which is a tool to lab c plus plus
libraries
automatically and then i will search
your dos
studio id photo
so for option typing
this slide this slide is very simple
it's just some
typical place you can write types
optionally so for variable declaration
you can
write types or you can just omit it and
also for
function parameters you can specify
types
also retain the type and for
class give definition you can also
spread the types or just omit them
and the type system that supported this
option typing is very simple
it's mostly installed instruction but
based type influence so there's not much
to say
but i will mention some other features
which
are enabled by this type system so the
first is the
instruction specialization
which is one of the lesson is the
program is the fa
the program writing this sound is fast
at least
at the interpolated language because
after type influence the virtual
instructions will be
specialized according to the operand
types
so here your plus two integers
after type influence the ad instruction
will be specialized to add
iii for for integers
and also it is that function
specialization
so if you write the function without a
explicit types when you call this
function with
some concrete types then this function
will be
specialized at the current side
based on the parameter types so this
function will be specialized to a
function for
an integer parameter and at this
sign it will be specialized for in the
function for
a string parameter um
another useful thing for option
typing the when you
when you write the extending codes
you see it can save you from
writing a lot a lot of vulnerable
employees
code to check parameter types because
when your wrapper function with this
signature
this function recorded with code under
the
the parameter which is passed to this
function
will be granted to have followed type
so you don't need to do type checking
here
and you just use it as a float
so here it's quite different from
writing
extending code for laura and
python because in those languages you
have to write a
query simon boilerplate code
the last phase i will
introduce is the dow synthesis maximum
thousand micron is mostly based on the
back some form so
fbnf expression can actually be viewed
as a pattern for both
matching and generating token sequences
so if you combine two bmf expressions
you can use one to match the source
syntax
and the other to deal with the tokens
for the target centers so here's
how the syntax how the syntax
look like for syntax micron so here
you define this is the syntax and how
you can optionally have a language id
which controls where this syntax
can be applied so here you
express your source syntax button and
how you
express the tag target sentence pattern
so here is an example in this example
the
plugin is for pattern grouping and the
extent exclamation and quality marks
and those knives are also
most are for globe global repeating
and the squad blockages for optional
group
which is equivalent to this
and in this in the sentence pattern you
can use some special variables
to represent the identifier
expression or a block of code
so here's an example margin
so in this space room you want to
support this kind of thing as well to
end
which is
lower like centers so this syntax we
transform this micron we transform this
sentence
to this one this is the native centers
of
uh of dao so
uh the
the compiler actually we deal with the
tree
for this pattern and deal with another
tree for
the target pattern
when the source code is matched to the
source pattern
the matched tokens way will be linked to
the
nodes in the source tree
so syntax tree
then the target sentence tree will be
used to deal with
those token sequences according
to some matching laws
so with this syntax you can write code
like this
which is entirely different from the
native data syntax
here i will briefly mention the code
searching method which is
like a code block in ruby
i mentioned this because there are some
examples used this kind of syntax
in the following slides so basically
you can pass a block of code as an
additional parameter
to a function this code block can be
attached to function
function call using this syntax
so here is an example of a built-in
built-in
code session method so
this method iterate on a list of
integers
and the integers the values and
the index will be passed to this
code block automatically and you can
specify
the variable names for for for those
you can also define user-defined code
assessing methods
um this may be a little bit complicated
um i don't know if i will have time to
explain this a lot i will come back if i
have time
thou also support the function
decorators
mixing classes and aspects
they are all incredible so i will
introduce one of
one by one so decorator is
a function functions that can modify
other functions
so here is a calculator and uh you
take a function at the parameter
in this stack loader you will you may
call this function
with the parameters with
with this special variable which uh
replaces
the parameters will be passed to the
function
and here it is so when you apply
a calculator you just put it before the
definition of this function
it looks like pattern decorated but it's
quite different
because in person decorated your
basically you evaluated this function
and then return a new function or an
object
to replace the original one but here
this decorator is just a template so
when you apply this decorator it will
generate a new
function based on this template so it's
uh quite different from python declared
and now i will speak a little bit about
mixing
so mixing are classes with members
which are injected from other classes
without inheritance
so the basic syntax is
to place the component class
in a pair of blockade
[Music]
so this so in this way
mix this class will have
additional members like values and
method this method
but this way this component will not be
the parent class
so here i will speak about the class
decrease
which i think is possibly
unique in this language so classically
there are classes
whose decorative methods will be
automatically
applied to the methods of mixing class
classes
so basically you can define some
methods as decorators and you can also
specify the pattern of the method
which this background can be applied to
so with this pattern
we need only methods with this breadth
uh
prefix will be modified by this
decorator
so in this mixing class this method will
be
decorated by this this decorator
so with this class decorated
here comes a lateral implementation of
aspect so as per the
assembly decorative classes but with
additional laws for automatic
application of the decorative classes
so here is basically a decorative
classes
with a lower which means this
decorative class will be applied to all
classes
with the names prefixed by math
ok now i started to speak about the
concurrent programming
in doubt there are multiple phases in
in doubt support concluding concurrent
programming
so the simplest is the synchronous
function call
and then there's the synchronous object
and then there's the
task community communication channel
which it
looked like which look like gold
channels
but it it you know they're everything
inspired by
go then there's a
built-in multi-floating modular mt
all these concurrent programming
features are
supported by a conculuent gap galaxy
connection
so here's the the synchronous function
function core so you just append a
double
you can exclamation marks
to a function call it will become
a synchronous a synchronous functioning
course executed in
a step in in separated task let
which are light-weighted
threads they retain
future values which can be used for
scheduling and retrieving result
so here's a simple uh example
so in this fountain we computed the sum
of
logarithms of some integers
so you can start as a single
plus com core it will return a future
value
so using this future value you can check
if the compute commutation i finished a
lot here just wait for
wait wait with the timeout if it's
time out you you can just print print
out some message
after it's finished you can
obtain the value of this function sorry
here i forgot to add a return sum
because
otherwise you do a lot good this time
here is a synchronous object
and a singular software is is a normal
object
but when it's created in a synchronous
mode or its method
will be called and executed
synchronously just like a singular
function call
and also such tasks are scheduled such
that
only one task led are active
at each time for the same instance so
here's an example so you have a class
for data clustering and
you create a an asynchronous
object with this double
exact exclamation marks and then you
call this method it will return
a future value just as a singular
function call
here you can do something else and check
for the
completion of this of this method
now here comes the task communication
channels
so channels allow your past data between
task labs
and perform some synchronization
between them the chinatown
is the implemented atlas customized c
data type that supports templates like
like type arguments
so here you can create a channel that
only allow passing integer types
with the capacity of capacity of five
so this type is a bit
look like a c plus plus template types
it provides several methods the most
important
tool are the method for sending and
receiving data
here are the signatures for the methods
[Music]
so here i will show you a simple example
so create a producer class
it will send some integers through a
channel
after you finish sending the integers it
will set the
capacity of the channel to yellow which
effectively close this channel
the second class is the consumer
consumer channel
consumer class it will receive
that data from the channel
and print it out when the channel is
closed
it will save data with the
with the finished status
so here you are created this channel and
the
include the
producer producer and the consumer as a
synchronous
object then you just simply learn
the method it will automatically started
the
communications and the synchronization
between them
the last feature we mentioned about is
the
mt modular for multiple flooding
it's a built-in modular it can be used
to
create a task list
but more importantly it can
it offers parallax code searching
methods
which can automatically paralyze some
some computations
so here is an example for the
empty start method which can be used to
cloud create a
task late so basically you can put
almost any code
in in this block which can will be
executed as a tasklet
here it's the same you have a future
value you can do the same
weighting and getting retaining the
result
so here is a list of the pilot method
so those method will
automatically parallel parallelize
the computation over an early nist
map
so for example the first one
simply iterated ten times using fourth
thread
and printed the the
index of the iteration out
and the same is the interlude over this
list
using fourth load and
here is the map that is
in the new new list using fourth
word here is to modify this
list using four thread
you can also search for a particular
item in a list
here you specify the county condition
for the
for the setting it will return the
interest
of the item which certifies this
condition
now i will speak a little bit about the
jitter compiler
it's implemented as a loadable modular
so your when you run down you simply
specify
and command line argument and this
module will be automatically loaded
uh still the compiler will be a tidal
companion will be
enabled so the back end of this compiler
is based on
lr vm and it
emphasizes on your local computation
it can only compile a subset of downward
machine
instructions that's why some programs
have
low speed up because there are a lot
sufficient deflection of numerical
computation
in the program so here is
some benchmarks it's the same table i
show you
in one of the first slides
so you can see that for some of the
problems the speed up is a little
normally good
but for the last two because those two
programs
don't have much new much numerical
computation so this low speed up
how much time the okay i think
now i will speak about the tour based on
clan granddaughter
it can be very easily used to
build guidance to see the plus plus
libraries
since it's based on clan it can
handle a widening of c plus plus
c c plus plus libraries
so it basically deal with bindings
directed from her defense
um it supported
c c plus plus functions c strat
structures and corpus c
plus plus classes and the inheritance
it also supports vertical watch function
and even a little template
since for some functions the type
in c and the c plus plus
are ambiguous so sometimes you have to
specify some hints for the wrapping
those hinges can be expressed as let's
see microns
so here's an example of the
input file for cloud calendar so your
your
cloud c file
in this ccr you can specify the modular
lane
using these microphones and you can
define
hints at micros so this hint
is to tell the tell client
that this function is is
in integer pointer but actually
it it should be an array of
sites three so the calendar will
automatically deal with the
codes which cheat this parameter as an
array
then you include the header files you
want to lock
then you can just run client down like a
sc plus plus compiler using
similar command line options
then you will generate the binding code
so use the calendar i have downloaded
the guidance for many
libraries like gsl
and also some labels for bioinformatics
and
some some labels for visualization
photographics political office
multimedia
graphic user interface and some other
other stuff
currently some of them are not updated
to the calendar
so if your time some of them may fail
but i will bring them
up to date
here is a screenshot for the
studio which here
i developed using qd4
so this um studio can support a
code editing and also
it has a console to run the code
and it also have a headlight debug
so i it
it has some interesting phase like it
support the simplest highlighting in the
console so when you write code in the
console
you gotta send this highlight it can
also support them
being like edit mode so you can use it
like a
veeam added
[Music]
so here is some future plans
since i spent most of time
for for developing the faces
so i i didn't spend much time for
documentation
so there are a lot of improvements for
the documentation
to be done there are also some possible
improvements
for the uh to the implementations i
planted it too
and also you need some
comprehensive unit tests
there are also some planned improv
employments to the cheetah compiler
client auto and
our studio
okay that's all thank you for your time
you